il est crucial que l'europe s'empare du
dossier méditerranéen c'est la volonté
d' emmanuel macron dans une allocution
aux armes et à la veille de la fête
nationale
évoquant le jeu de nouvelles puissances
le président estime que l'europe 200
palettes à des dossiers géopolitiques
méditerranéen et rester maître de son
destin sans le laisser à d'autres
puissances
évoquant sans les nommer la turquie et à
la russie siens la zone méditerranée
sera le défi des prochaines années tant
les facteurs de crise qui s'y conjuguent
sont nombreux contestations des zones
maritimes affrontements entre pays
riverains déstabilisation de la libye
migration trafic accès aux ressources un
jeu de nouvelles puissances
si nous aussi l'europe à haïr redéfinir
son rôle et sa place sans naïveté sans
complaisance s'agissant de la libye je
veux redire ici combien sa stabilisation
est fondamentale pour la sécurité de
l'europe et du sel
c'est pourquoi j'appelle à la reprise
immédiate des négociations et d'un
dialogue politique en vue d'un cessez le
feu
et pour en parler en direct avec moi
emmanuel dupuis président d'un institut
prospective et c'est qu'ils ont été en
europe
emmanuel dupuis bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur la rt france alors
emmanuel macron veut que l'europe
redéfinissent son rôle dans cette zone
comment petit faire cela écoutez je
pense que le président a parfaitement
résumé la situation en évoquant les
points les plus litigieux qui nous
oblige à redéfinir une politique
méditerranéenne de l'union européenne du
reste il avait tenté de le faire l'année
dernière en invitant une centaine de
personnes issues des sociétés civiles
des deux rives
ça s'appelait d'ailleurs le sommet des
deux rives et ça devait la deuxième
édition pardon devait se tenir cette
année le grenat virus
on a décidé autrement je crois que le
président ait dans une séquence très
méditerranéenne il va recevoir demain le
premier ministre espagnol très tôt
sanchez la candidature malheureusement
de la connaître espagnol part donc à la
tête de l'eurogroupe activement soutenue
par la france n'a pas pu aboutir au
profit de la candidature irlandaise est
long on a aussi eu la certitude que le
rapprochement entre la france l'espagne
et l'italie est aussi une réalité
périphériques à la méditerranée puisque
à l'occasion du dernier sommet du g5
celle à un hot shots
le premier ministre espagnol andres
sanchez accompagnait le président et le
président du conseil je souhaitais
comptait participer à virer conférant
aux qu'il a prise en compte ou une
reprise on compte de l'agenda
méditerranéen pour plusieurs raisons
premièrement le corner virus a confirmé
le fait qu'il fallait repenser la
colocalisation ou la relocalisation d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises de
souveraineté et de ce point de vue les
faibles taux de d'exploitation et la
nécessité de coopérer avec nos voisins
du sud
et pour le coup un potentiel que nous
avons pour l'instant sont insuffisamment
mise en avant deuxièmement le fait que
nous sommes dans une séquence symbolique
anniversaire en célébrant pardon le 25e
anniversaire de la coopération
euro-méditerranéenne
ça va se dérouler en novembre prochain
le président a symboliquement
nécessité ou une capacité de méridionale
ise soit nouvelle approche de l'union
européenne dans un contact sera aussi
qui ne lui est pas favorable ou qui
n'est pas favorable à la france puisque
l'allemagne assume la présidence
semestrielle de l'union européenne
ensuite ce sera le cas du portugal
ensuite la slovénie et la france
n'assumera ce rôle qu'au premier
semestre 2022 donc je pense que le
président en prenant sont les mots qu'il
a eus à l'occasion d'une queue de son
discours aux armées à l'hôtel de brial
hier a sans doute deux visions des
choses une vision optimiste ce que
pourrait être cette que la terre
méditerranéen et le leadership qu'il
souhaite voir jouer la france
et puis comme ça a été rappelé les
nombreux facteurs de déstabilisation
d'une certaine façon se cristallisent en
méditerranée orientale
l'ensemble des facteurs qui interroge
notre politique étrangère
notre marginalisation dans le décès
libyens au profit d'une passe turcot
russe qui s'affirme de plus en plus les
réflexions autour des nouveaux enjeux
énergétiques qui ne sont pas à notre
profit mais bien à ceux qui sont en
train de refaire les zones économiques
exclusives et donc de remettre en cause
le droit maritime nos mémoires la
turquie est bien évidemment la question
migratoire qui reste une épée de
damoclès brandie au dessus de nos têtes
nonobstant le fait que nous avons pour
cela négocier avec la turquie mais dans
des conditions qui nous étaient pas
forcément putsch et de la morale oui
vous venez de le dire il ya beaucoup de
facteurs de tension qui se multiplient
en ces derniers temps dans la zone
méditerranéenne les contestations des
zones maritimes des affrontements entre
pays riverains et puis surtout en tout
cas la crise libyenne la fesa libyens
dont a parlé emmanuel macron je cite un
il appelé à la reprise immédiate des
négociations et d'un dialogue politique
en libye
alors mon métier à la table bobo
pourparlers là aussi c'est un paradoxe
le président email macron appel cessez
le feu et d'aucuns diraient qu'ils
appellent un cessez le feu parce que le
soutien que nous avons
cordes et peut-être trop bruyamment ou
de manière peut-être trop visible au
maréchal et retard a capoté puisque son
opération comme chacun sait est en train
de se retourner contre lui
avec la montée en puissance de la
présence militaire turc lié à l'accord
de défense qui lie le gouvernement
d'international et la turquie depuis le
27 novembre dernier le président en
appelant à un cessez le feu a en tête le
fait que la turquie et la russie peuvent
parfaitement s'entendre et donc du coup
en nous marginalise en nous de fête pays
européens qui n'avons pas vu jusqu'à
présent une politique convergentes
on sait les divergences le hiatus qui a
pu exister entre la france et d'italie
qu'a tenté malgré tout mais pas
suffisamment de 2,2 d'assumer ou
d'essayer de de résorber la conférence
de berlin en janvier dernier et puis
bien évidemment un autre élément qui je
crois est tout à fait important la
montée en puissance des pays régionaux
je crois que l'algérie va jouer un rôle
tout à fait déterminant pour la
stabilisation en libye l'homme inutile
évidemment de rappeler que les tensions
entre la france et l'algérie nous
rendent pas forcément les choses aisées
là encore une fois et de ce point de vue
il faudra voir comment la france et
l'algérie dans les prochaines semaines
pourront essayer de faire converger
leurs positions le président tebboune a
semblé tendre la main vers normalisation
des relations avec la france
maintenant c'est à la france de faire ce
geste que demandent les autorités
algériennes monsieur depuis merci
d'avoir est en direct avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe merci à vous